what's happening reject nation we're
gonna watch from a channel that i
actually love
quite a bit don't think i've ever
reacted to i think you reacted to a
short film that he did forever ago
um but it's from star wars theory it's
called mace windu's return in the
mandalorian season two
at the top of his description box he
says all right i know a lot of you
missed the theories and so do i and
here's one that at first glance will
make you roll your eyes by the end of
this video
i think you'll be able to see a lot of
the plausibility of things
so i'm excited to check this out
seriously i mean star wars theory is an
amazing channels
and i i often buy into his theories too
if you guys haven't seen our mandalorian
reaction to the latest episode
it's up on youtube now and i also want
to say thank you to everyone who watched
that announcement video i put up
yesterday
got a lot of a lot of engagement i'll
put it like that there's a lot of
engagement and i really appreciate all
the support like it it really
really means the world to me so if you
haven't seen that you can go ahead and
check that out too but
sincerely uh it means a lot thank you
your boy
all right i know a lot of you miss the
theories and so do i
so here's one that at first glance will
probably make a lot of people roll their
eyes
but by the time you finish this video i
think you'll be able to see a lot of the
plausibility of this actually
happening maybe the more i write this
theory the more it makes sense but first
we need to understand
a lot of lore and backstory so sit more
backstory cannon star wars revenge of
the sith mace windu fell out the window
and we haven't seen the jedi launched
out the window we saw a figment of his
return in one of the vader comics by
marvel which
i have fully covered on with voice
acting and
everything if you can really call it
voice acting now this mace
isn't really mace it's some weird
fragmented
animated version of him just like the
padme in that story
really wasn't padme with that being the
only real quote unquote
return of mace windu can we say that
he's truly dead now in this theory i'm
going to say that he didn't die that day
i rise to scott walker he is we've heard
his voice speak to rey in the rise of
skywalker and you're also probably
thinking
well that definitely means he's dead
right sure maybe
but how did he speak to rey this is
where all the lord backstory comes in
and then we'll get to the theory of how
he's in mando and
his death if it wasn't for qui-gon jinn
no one would be a forced ghost
hwang jin met the shaman of the wills
now these were ancient
powerful beings almost like priests of
some sorts
during qui-gon's life they taught him
how to transfer his essence beyond death
however due to his untimely demise at
the hands of darth maul
due to his age and well just being
bested at that point
overseeing maul's attack really and
catching him off guard he wasn't able to
complete his training with the whales
therefore only able to manifest his
voice as a ghost
and not his body until much later near a
new hope which can be read in the book
from a certain point of view which i've
also covered in a vid now in episode
three
qui-gon's force ghost speaks to yoda it
was cut from the film but it was
dialogue in the deleted scenes oh i
didn't know that
and it was written in the original
script it's that moment on polish masa
where yoda is meditating during padme's
labor
through which baylor the future adopted
father of
leia interrupts yoda's communication
with qui god once padme dies
and obi-wan and yoda speak we learn that
qui-god is now yoda's master
who has taught him how to commune with
him in the force toby was surprised
really very much around in the force
really that we see or hear from him in
the kenobi show okay
so now you're like whoa i didn't know
that
theory mace windu didn't know how to
transfer his essence into the force
not yet when he fell out the window he
had to have survived to somehow learn
this ability
from someone otherwise he wouldn't have
been able to talk to rey
okay so to play devil's advocate against
my own theory here i could say well
anakin also didn't have time to learn
this technique as stated in the rise and
fall of darth vader's book where
as he died near luke anakin simply heard
obi-wan's voice in his head
speak to him through the force
instructing him to do as he says and
become one with the force
or else he will cease to exist now it is
possible that qui-gon reached out to me
so
do but then it raises the question why
didn't mace reach out to yoda as well
since mace was the first to die in order
66 perhaps he didn't perfect it yet
but i mean there's just too many plot
holes there for me to make a proper
anti-theory to my theory having died
when he was tossed out the window
of course we've seen jackson also say
that jedi can fall from
very high distances which is true they
can't mace just
lost a hand which literally everyone in
star wars has
he was cooked a little bit but he was
extremely powerful so it's
very possible that he could have
actually survived okay so where did he
go the star wars galaxy is huge
and it's possible that he fled somewhere
or went into hiding just like yoda and
obi-wan and the rest of the survivors of
order 66
what if he went somewhere to some
unknown planet in the unknown regions
somewhere to hide and train more jedi
tattooing
[Music]
i like
however while we do know that he won
fair and square
i did have the privilege of asking ian
mcdermott a celebration
if palpatine faked his loss to mace
windu so that he could put anakin in
that position of
urgency to turn him into the dark side
ian mcdermott
as he was signing my lightsaber replied
with a certain yes
however of course this is a question
that i'd want to ask george lucas who
has confirmed
that samuel jackson did in fact beat
palpatine but i would like to ask him
again
or maybe i just need to accept that mace
windu is more powerful than the emperor
anyways if mace is alive seeing him as a
mandalorian
would not just be cool it would fit a
lot of the story for the jedi that could
help reunite the child with a species
there is no person in the galaxy that
knows yoda better than mace windu
in fact he knows him better than
lukewood mesa sat with yoda as second in
command and in some cases
first in command master windu in a lot
of ways could have been the chosen one
if he had brought balance
he was certainly powerful enough he used
the light side and the dark
he was the master of his emotions and he
had surpassed all of his teachers as a
young boy
growing to become the most powerful jedi
just before anakin could see his full
potential
until of course he lost to obi-wan or
should i say lost to his own arrogance
so let's say mando
takes the child to ahsoka and she
eventually tells him that
she's not really a jedi anymore so
someone
she knows who can really show him the
way to reuniting the child with this
species is of course mace windu
and she points him to this easter egg
like hunt in season three or four
or something throughout the galaxy to
find mace windu
when we finally do now i could see mace
live in his life almost like thanos in
infinity war
an old jedi master laying low perhaps
growing his props and training those who
exhibited forced powers at an early age
turning
[Music]
and obi-wan after their deaths perhaps
even coming across luke skywalker
and learning of the fate of anakin and
the emperor teaching luke so much about
his father's youth
this could be mace's return this could
be how mace fits into the mandalorian
so you're probably saying well okay but
what about his death
well what if while amanda is finding the
path to mace windu
he is followed by someone notorious
flying the slave one
ship and once he does leave mace with
the information on where to unite the
child with his parents
boba comes in and how poetic would it be
if mace windu's death came
full circle with a disintegration and
what i mean
is boba fett finds him and kills him
transcending mace into the force
and boba avenging his father django hey
one day
i had a feeling it would somehow tie
back into boba fett which i think would
be really neat because
as we know he killed jane gofet boba
fett was there an attack of the clones
and all sad and then in clone wars
there's several episodes dedicated to
boba fett falling down the wrong side of
the tracks and specifically
wanting to avenge his father and go
after and kill mace windu which
obviously he doesn't succeed in
long story short there's a few dedicated
episodes to it that you guys can watch
but
they're pretty pretty damn cool and they
give you really good insight into boba
fett but i do think just the theory
alone of bringing
it full circle with boba fett now
officially establishing the mandalorian
to be a character and we still don't
know what his deal is with the character
in the mandalorian he's supposed to have
a bigger role soon to come
it could be like towards the end of this
season it could be next season we don't
know yet but for sure he's supposed to
be a bigger character at some point i
could see that theory landing
in some way where maybe when boba fett
develops a relationship with denjarin
and maybe they
work together help each other out or
boba fett helps him out in some way or
maybe it's just a conflict over the
armor trying to get it back or something
right
who knows but it could easily lead to
him like stalking him or tracking him
if he knows danjarin is going after mace
windu i do love the concept though of
bringing that full circle there was a
lot that little boba fett and clone wars
had to learn
a lot of life lessons he had to pick up
but it would be a pretty sweet full
circle to happen
if he was to take out mace windu
ultimately and turn him into an official
force ghost
i haven't read any star wars book ever
in my life or even a comic book but from
seeing a lot of mace windu in the clone
wars
all the personality traits and the
caliber of power that he has i don't
really feel like it's on display
in the movies you could probably pick up
on it if you've seen clone wars or
something i feel like especially for
fans of that show
to tie it in here for the mandalorian
i'd be down man i mean that sounds like
a great ass theory and i would love it i
mean
come on like you you know yeah of course
he could survive
that that incident become a
well-established movie trope now that if
somebody
if you don't witness the actual moment
of a character's death they could easily
not be dead for a
million reasons and yeah i totally could
see mace windu surviving that somehow i
mean yeah in bad shape needing to recoup
but in the star wars universe and after
boba fett just came back like mace windu
could probably
sure come back and yeah i really love
this theory too because it's a totally
mandalorian style predicament yeah
maybe they have an uneasy alliance of
some kind boba fett and dinjar and
having to go
i need mace windu because of the child
so you can't just kill him but then i
know that you know once our arrangement
ends
you get to do what you have to do like
you know and and there's a conflict
there that i'm already getting excited
uh excited about plus the mandalorian i
think is one of those shows now too
where people
want to get their chance to jump in no
matter what
you knows caliber role and for a guy
like sam jackson and a
you know famous character like mace
windu that might be a cool way to
bring that capability from the extended
star wars universe to the live action
screen do it justice there in a place
where it seems like a perfect arena for
it
true you know i yeah i love this theory
too and also just the
ideas brought in about you know from the
outside media about the force ghosts and
whatnot
qui-gon's additional presence as you
know yoda's mentor and then perhaps
maybe even by extension mace windu's
mentor
made me more excited for obi-wan's show
like kind of in hearing about that stuff
too so
i mean i feel like if we get once we get
the kenobi show i think we need a
qui-gon
presence however you know i i do think
though that with the socatano yes she
left the jedi order behind but she's
still
she's still essentially a jedi she still
is very much
in tune with the force is capable of
communicating with yoda
as well she might not be an established
jedi in the jedi order but
i do think undoubtedly even when you
leave off with her in rebels she still
is very much capable of communicating
with yoda i think you could still use
ahsoka tano in the show
to get to talking to yoda to find out
more about baby yoda the child
undoubtedly i'm not sure if like it's
structurally speaking i feel like that
might be kind of annoying you meet bo
katan and you know about the child
go to ahsoka tana
[Laughter]
i don't want it to come at the expense
of
ahsoka tano's impact and presence on the
show yeah i don't want to cheapen that
in any way just to
get you know ooh more cool star wars
stuff in here you know because yeah you
you could also have handled poorly
teeter into that territory
but i do think for the boba fett arc
to fully serve his ark you establish him
an attack of the clones that ending shot
with him in attack of the clones and
then clone wars his whole mission of
wanting to kill mace windu and he's kind
of
nothing really like let's face it guys
empire's right he's like a cool dude but
he's not really a character he's a toy
he's an action figure but then to really
bring him back here
and um after surviving the sarlacc pit
and then knowing that
his core wound was based off of this
revenge
mission you know at least him having
some type of encounter with mace windu
i think would be fulfilling guys what do
you think about this theory leave your
comments down below
subscribe to star wars 30 if you haven't
done so already if you're a star wars
fan you just oughta
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell last but not least
let's do a
sarah campbell sarah campbell is someone
who's constantly in our late night live
streams
and i'm always happy to have her there
she's constantly contributing to our
streams and she's a recent patron of
jack who called us for a patron of the
day shout out welcome
now the unfortunate part is just because
of the way we have organized our shout
outs
you're here for a star wars video shout
out and from my understanding
you've never seen a star wars with all
your heart and you get really upset when
they deviate from the mythology that
you've invested so much time in
but sarah still i'll let you know what
video your shout outs
and we want to give you a traditional
shout out here so s
stands for super tuper ooh
a stands for admirable r
stands for righteous a stands for
also amazing h stands for
honorable so many great qualities about
you
sarah you are just the best human being
in the world apparently
you've done it share the wisdom with the
rest of us
hopefully you're not writing up too many
people as you're working in hr
and you know don't don't overstep any
boundaries
don't be toby you know what i mean but
thank you so much for being here
much love to you you be safe
[Music]